one of the kind of main themes I think
of of public discussion certainly in
kind of in the Twittersphere and
blogosphere and then politics now is is
privileges oppression is structural
inequality all this kind of stuff
where do you come down on that well what
about say with the concept of white
privilege
I think it's garbage completely I think
it's utter garbage
I think someone could argue that there
in any given country you may have some
form of majority privilege I mean the
whole thing of white privilege is it's
it's essentially a little essay or paper
by some woman that when that went way
too far right you know they had that
whole um I can't remember the name of
the woman who first wrote the paper on
it in the invisible knapsack and
whatever it was in a relatively short
paper just with this idea of white
privilege right it was just kind of an
idea and for whatever reason over the
past few decades people kind of refound
this paper and ran with it and so now
you've got politicians and you've got
actors and you've got just general
people talking about this whole concept
so I'm I don't think it exists and
there's people who criticize me for that
I think I think that's a garbage concept
and I thought and I think it's a harmful
concept it's not just that it's not just
that I am I don't believe it exists I
actually think it's a terrible concept
to try to ingrain in people all these
forms of privilege right if you're
trying to tell males that they have male
privilege you're trying to tell white
males they have white white privilege
and male privilege and heterosexual
privilege and this and you're trying to
create this whole what is it Jordan
Peterson always refers in the postmodern
neo-marxist it's kind of becoming me I
mean by now right but um but it is true
because it's it's destructive so this is
the problem I I don't I don't support
any one I think that yeah like one I
don't think it's true I think that
factually like when I see them when
someone talks about why Pilar's are my
okay tell me what exactly you mean by
that the things they say generally don't
have anything to do again oftentimes
they could just fall into majority
privilege so they might say stuff like
um oh if you buy a plaster it's the
color
it's closer to a white person skin color
than then black person's it's like okay
but if you go to Africa it's the
opposite because that's the majority or
when you're watching TV you're more
likely to see white faces on TV and then
black faces are agent like you're in
England I mean like you're in England if
you go to Nigeria everything's like
every everyone's about you looking at an
ad you look on TV look at the films
everyone's black it's like because
you're in Nigeria if you go to China
same thing you know it's not it's not
rocket science
I've heard people say stuff like if you
inish in in the shampoo in hotel
bathrooms works better on white people's
hair than it works on afro hair and
again I'm like what country are you in
why why would you expect they're gonna
have some special niche black afro
shampoo in I don't know Cambridge in a
hotel and and then and then similarly
I'm kind of like look even these are the
things people have to complain about
like stuff must be pleated pretty
frickin sorry peep stuff must be pretty
freakin good
yeah if this is what you are complaining
about right if these are your examples
and so the best you're coming at me with
that I'm like like throw that thing out
the window and then secondly I just
think that it's um I think it's quite a
racist idea to be honest with you I
think it's a very racist idea to start
claiming based on people's skin colour
based on people's sex based on people's
sexuality assuming they have some kind
of advantage or disadvantage that
they've just inherited and that no
matter what they do you know they need
to kind of acknowledge it and atone for
it and check their privilege and you can
now kind of beat them with the stick
right every time you say something I
don't like I can say well you're using
your white male privilege to it to
victimize me well let me use some of my
privilege try and push back on some case
go the sake of because I hear a lot of
what you're saying yeah but a lot of
people might say well if you and I were
walking down the street in this country
I am NOT from here you actually were
born here unlike me right but the police
would treat us differently because I'm
white and you're black according to what
well black people are more likely to be
prosecuted black people are more likely
to get a longer sentence a harsher
sentence for the same crime people say
you're more likely to be arrested etc
right for what arrested for what if we
if arrested for what I mean you more
likely to be less ace you're more likely
to be stopped and searched right we know
that okay well I can London or something
yeah yeah okay yeah that's um there's a
couple reasons for them okay so the
whole stop and search think that's a
that's a good that's a complicated
that's a complicated issue I mean there
are see there everything has like a flip
side so the flip side of this one is
obviously in certain areas in certain
cities in certain countries the
breakdown of demographics who commit
certain crimes is different okay so if
you were looking if you're if the police
are trying to sort out knife crime in
London take the obvious example in
violent crime in London violent crime in
Chicago in the USA take some obvious
examples vast majority of perpetrators
are young black men vast majority of
victims are young black men so does that
mean that the police this is where the
nuance comes in and people try to avoid
the nuance right does that mean that the
police should then go out and just
target all young black men because they
know that that's the demographic that
commits those crimes at a higher rate
no because the vast majority of young
black men do not commit any crime so
it's a it's a it's a complex this one's
a complex one right people always try to
make it more very simple because they'll
say black people get arrested at higher
rates or are more likely to be stopped
by police and then it's like okay yeah
but that demographic is also committing
more crime so how do we and people
oftentimes people won't want to
acknowledge that fact because it's not
convenient to their argument but it's
like okay you need to put both these
things on the table and recognize what
the facts are and then you can actually
have a proper discussion of okay well
what's the given these are the stats we
might not like the stats but given these
are the stats how can we know
address this issue
[Music]